foreign
[Music]
the three Muslims minus one but on Hell
sends his alarms regardless inshallah
how's it going around me
I'm doing good man how are you home if
you guys miss Anjo inshallah stay tuned
for Saturday 12 p.m EST the three
selfies are gonna be back inshallah with
this being said Rami do you want to give
a quick little introduction into what's
been going on lately yeah so uh we we
discussed and we noticed between the
three of us that there's a lot of Basics
that are lacking with Muslims right a
lot of Muslims lack Basics whether it's
in the work field or it's in their Islam
or it's in day-to-day interactions a lot
of people lack the basics and I was
talking to my brother about this
sometimes you need people to teach you
how to do basic things even if it's
something small like shopping or
interacting with people communicating
you need people to show you how to do
basic things and if you don't get the
basics down then you're going to be
struggling to do these very basic things
so we actually decided that it would be
best to go through some of the basics
islamically speaking so that people can
walk away with
um something more practical that they
can take in their day-to-day experiences
inshallah that's amazing bro and this is
exactly why inshallah y'all can stay
tuned for a little bit more basic
foundational and beneficial content
going forward inshallah
um so this being said today there's a
couple things that you know we want to
talk about but firstly before we jump
right into it I wanted to share some
good news alhamdulillah so there is a
brother I'm not going to name any
mentioned I'm not going to mention any
name because perhaps he wants anonymity
um but he's from the UK Abdullah and I
had a call with him a few days ago and
there's a lot of stuff you know we don't
film and they're you know off camera
um but this was a very heartwarming
story so I wanted to share it because
there's a message but this brother
alhamdulillah he had been researching
Islam for a long time uh probably not
too long but he knows it's the truth and
he even knows that you know even
subconsciously internally he might
already be Muslim because we
subconsciously Embrace and accept Islam
and submit to Allah before we verbalize
the shahada and he told me that he's
delaying the shahada
and I asked him why and he said that you
know what I want to do it in a you know
more ideal time you know I want to make
it a special day with my boys and I want
to go to the Masjid I want the Sheikh
involved and it's a very good intention
right but necessarily might not be the
best action
and a lot of people are like what are
you talking about how is there a
difference between intention and action
I thought anything that I mean well is
well and anything that I mean harm is
harm but it's a little bit deeper than
that but bear with me for now so I
talked to him and I asked him like okay
that's cool and I'm not trying to do
fear-mongering because at the end of the
day you're already in a state where you
accept Islam and you know like you're
gonna eventually say that shahada why
not just do it right now what is the
delay because I hear a lot of people say
I want to finish the code and I want to
finish at least reading it once what's
after that you know what I mean there's
so much to learn about Islam and to me I
believe that if you're in a state of
paralysis by analysis and this brother
was alluding to a little bit of how he
wants to write his wrongs and Affairs
between him and Allah before accepting
Islam so kind of in a way where once his
slate gets wiped out clean he doesn't
taint it not even the tiniest Speck of
dirt and that's a very admirable or
honorable intention right
but what is guaranteed in this life
except death you know and I told him
that if you want to come from a place
where you want to fix all these things
that's fine but understand if you accept
Islam now on the day of judgment no one
can ask you
um why did you not accept Islam after
Allah has made it clear as day to you
why did you why did you delay it and no
excuse will hold any bit of weight on
that day believe me and there's so many
people that are wondering how am I going
to be rewarded if I'm struggling well
think about it like this let's say a
sister is coming from 20 x amount of
years of not wearing hijab she's not
Muslim and she's struggling with hijab
it's not going to make sense for her to
overnight via nakabi or hijabi it's not
going to make sense I would much rather
she accepts Islam because she submits to
it to be the truth and then struggles
with her hijab for the sake of Allah and
Allah will actually reward her more
every single day that she's fighting
that internal battle and trying to work
towards having correct hijab then a
sister perhaps let's say has never had a
struggle with it she was born Muslim
never struggled with it didn't come to
the West wasn't a feminist whatever you
get me so similarly I told him yes you
can fix all your Affairs but that's not
an obligation Allah doesn't expect
Perfection Allah expects progress and
he's like okay I get that but you know
what if it's not that much more delayed
it's only a week you know and it's gonna
be the Majid and it's it's gonna be nice
and I've already said the shahada before
and I was like okay when you said it did
you mean it or did you just say it to
learn how to say it with intent and he's
like no it's a ladder you know like I
went over it to basically prepare myself
to say it but it wasn't like the the
shahada quote-unquote and I was like
okay there's no there's no problem with
that and again I'm not gonna pressure
him because at the end of the day I want
people to embrace Islam and stay Muslim
then just say something empty where they
might verbalize the shahada but it's not
really here and then eventually leave
Islam even though that's not in our
control but I want to make sure they're
ready to take that step so I told his
brother that you know alhamdulillah you
have all the time you want and just
understand again not fear-mongering but
anything can happen to us nothing's
guaranteed if I were you I would
definitely take that step to become a
Muslim and not delay it because it's
shaytan's tricks to make you delay it
shaytan's gonna tell you there's a
perfect moment wait till you do this you
don't deserve Islam you're not gonna be
forgiven XYZ
alhamdulillah we ended the call this was
Monday nothing happened
and I woke up today to a text message
from the brother
saying that alhamdulillah right after a
phone call on Monday he said that
shahada immediately
and subhanallah what happened was as
soon as he became a Muslim and did the
shahada the very next morning he felt
very terminally ill like I'm talking
like ill to the point where he wouldn't
have been able to go to the Masjid let
alone like leave the house or do what he
planned basically this whole Grand
ideological fairy tale type of and not
in a disrespectful way but just this
nice prepared way of saying the shahada
he wouldn't have been able to do it
anyway
and I remember telling him that too that
what's not to say that once it comes the
day to go to the Masjid let's say the
Sheikh can't come or let's say something
happens to a family member where they're
ill and because of that you got to
attend to caring for them and you can't
come and it just goes to show the timing
that subhanallah like had he delayed it
and Allah knows best perhaps because of
that he might not have still been Muslim
and Allah knows what would have happened
but because he failed because he passed
that test and he didn't fail that step
we have a new brother in Islam
alhamdulillah and this is a reminder to
everyone here that if you're Muslim or
not Muslim
having good intention is not everything
good action is very important and I
would say sometimes even more important
than good intention but Romney what do
you think about that
first I wanted to ask what is what do
you mean by good intention what does
that actually mean so good intention is
having a pure intention where you intend
to do something for the sake of Allah
you intend to do something for the
betterment of Allah or not betterment of
Allah to please Allah and only please
Allah to help people to serve people
your your goal is not for Dunya your
goal is not to appease the people or
just your own desires or enoughs and
this is not to go on a tangent where
your own nuffs and pleasing your desires
can't always you know equate to pleasing
Allah because sometimes you know doing
what I want to do is also going to
please Allah uh but the goal should be
always to please Allah and doing it for
the sake of Allah
okay and what about good action what is
that so good good action so the thing
with good action is good action is
necessarily uh not going to be doing
good action okay let me let me break it
down like this
a good action is an act which is good
which is beneficial and this was also
please Allah however you can have a good
action with a bad intention I'll give
you an example let's say I want to give
a lot of silica I want to feed a bunch
of homeless people right this is an
amazing amazing
action in the eyes of Allah because it's
feeding people that are in need I'm
giving meals away that's fine however
what if my main intention for this was
to get clout I want to record it I want
to bring Rami Rami we're going to go you
know over here to Popeyes we're gonna
buy 22 piece boxes I'm gonna pass you my
iPhone I'm gonna put on the the mic and
we're gonna record it I'm going to start
with solemnly come brothers and sisters
you know today we're going to be doing a
little bit of Street Dao and whatever
and my main intention was just to do
this for views just to do this for Subs
this is a very good action but it's a
very bad intention my intention isn't
for the sake of Allah or to actually
feed people and keep it low-key
oftentimes doing a lot of things between
you and Allah keeping your good deeds
private it's much more honorable as we
know from Islam
um
and doing otherwise isn't necessarily
always beneficial like this case and the
opposite could be true wrong because a
lot of people are wondering like okay I
get that what about bad intention uh
sorry what about good intention bad
action what is that about so let's say I
have a very good intention but I'm not
going to have bad action I'll give you
an example let's say
some guy is having a Haram relationship
with a girl who's not Muslim I know
crazy right like concept but it happens
unfortunately and this guy decides you
know what I want to stay with this girl
I'm going to be committing Haram with
her but you know she knows I'm Muslim so
I eventually want to bring her into
Islam I eventually want to convert her
to Islam and give her dawa and whatever
but he stays with this girl he stays
committing Haram
this
in his mind could be tricked into being
a good intention I want to bring another
human being into Islam and I want to
guide them and I want to give them uh
knowledge give them that Allah to the
point where Allah can give them but it's
a very bad action
another thing could be let's say
um
I want to I don't know
I want to build a Masjid it's a very
good intention right
amazing intention I want to build a
Masjid so you know what I'm going to rob
a bank now so I have enough money to
build that Masjid very bad action
so we must understand as Muslims we have
to have good intention and good action
combined side by side it can't be one
without the other one of the hadiths of
uh the 40 Hadith
is the prophet saw mentions that Deeds
are judged by nothing but their
intention
like actions are judged by nothing but
their intention intention is the thing
that matters the most when you do good
deeds even good intention and good
action
is the key to success inshaallah
inshallah so basically what you're
saying is in order to actually be
rewarded by Allah to have good deeds you
have to do something Allah tells you is
good
and you have to do it for his sake as
well
sorry can you repeat that one more time
I was reading these comments no worries
so basically what you're saying is you
have to do something that Allah tells
you is good and you have to do it for
his sake
definitely definitely 100 okay perfect
because we can't we can't just do things
for God let alone acts of worship that
we think are good but they might not
even be acts of worship to begin with a
lot of people don't know that in Islam
the the general you know we're not
Scholars here but in generality
everything is halal permissible unless
explicitly mentioned to be Haram yeah or
not explicitly in Quran Sunnah but let's
say majority scholar consensus you want
to follow that
um these are things we we stay away from
however the default for ibada acts of
worship is the opposite that all of
these acts of worship are Haram unless
specifically mentioned to be Halal or to
be obligatory
yeah absolutely absolutely so it took me
a second but um okay so I want to give
an example because like imagine you want
to take your wife to a dinner or
something right so you take her to your
favorite restaurant instead of hers you
know it's like you have a good intention
I want to take you out for a good time
but instead of taking her to her
favorite place you take her to your
favorite place so who's it really for if
it's to make her happy and to give her a
good time why are you going to your
favorite place it's like you know I want
to do something for the sake of Allah
but you're not doing things that Allah
actually likes you're doing things that
you want to do so you have to make sure
that this is something that Allah loves
how do we know that Allah loves some
actions because he tells us the prophet
salaam he said in the Allah
the most beloved acts to him are those
which he made obligatory
the things are obligations for us when
we do them Allah loves that over the
other Deeds we also know Allah loves the
Deeds that are consistent even if
they're small right which actually kind
of brings us to a topic we're going to
be talking about in a bit inshallah
which is about
you know professionalism and Excellency
and doing things to the best of your
ability consistency is going to be a big
part of that as well inshallah but um
let's let's wrap up this topic so again
intentions
intentions are or good intention is when
you do something for the sake of Allah
as opposed to doing it for like a
worldly gain and there's a very scary
Hadith in the process Adam I don't know
how authentic it is but it's it's this
is truthful in concept so it's okay
inshallah the prophet peace be upon him
he said that the the actions of the
afterlife things you do to elevate
yourself in the afterlife will be done
for the Dunya for example you know what
we're doing now
you know giving dawa or what we call
giving Dao or teaching people about
Islam instead of doing it for the sake
of Allah people will do it for the Dunya
oh I'm doing it for the followers and
the views and the money and the subs and
the blah blah whatever whatever
you know
so that is a great example of you know
someone who might not do something for
the sake of Allah
and how they'll actually be punished in
the afterlife because of it so you have
good intentions for the sake of Allah
then you have good actions which are
things that Allah commands you to do or
tells you to do or tells you that
they're good things to do
and um is there anything I misfired yeah
I wanted to quickly touch on the
consequences so basically the
consequences of doing things for the
sake of Allah versus your main Nia being
not for the sake of Allah
so the first thing I want you all to
understand is
anytime we do something for the sake of
Allah we do it to please Allah and Obey
Allah and no one else nothing else
we can't fail we can't lose
even if in Dunya in hindsight it seems
like we might be letting go of something
that we want I'll give an example
let's say
I really want to listen to music right I
feel like it's going to make me happy I
feel like it's gonna give me a better
pump in the gym right it's gonna give me
some energy some motivation some
whatever right thing but whatever we'll
keep it that
and because of that I think it's
beneficial for me right but I know you
know what musical instruments are Haram
shouldn't be listening to music and I
don't want to do that because you know
it's for Allah's sake and I'm here
battling like should I do it should I
not
and I'm thinking you know what if I go
to the gym like logically rationally and
I lift heavier I'll become bigger or
become stronger how is that a bad thing
and the flip side is okay you know what
I'm not going to do it just for the sake
of Allah
the main point that I'm getting to is if
you ever forego something Haram for the
sake of Allah or you do something that
is good for you for the sake of Allah
you'll never lose however anytime you do
things for ulterior motives or Dunya or
people
it's almost every single time nine times
out of ten eventually going to lead to a
point where you just either a miserable
B stuck in this Loop of only seeking
validation from Dunya and people or C
taking yourself away from Allah
a very good example of this is let's say
I want to give
I don't know I want to buy someone lunch
for the sake of Allah right and let's
say they're sick they just had surgery
and they're recovering and they might
not have energy to leave the house so
I'm gonna give them I'm gonna go to take
out I'm gonna go get their favorite
restaurant their favorite drink favorite
entree and I'm gonna leave that at the
doorstep or I'm gonna just you know tell
them that you know drop it off
my intention if it's for the sake of
Allah
versus my intention for the sake of them
are two different things a lot of people
are like why isn't that the same thing
let's say I do it with the intention of
pleasing them and only that
we're all human at the end of the day
what if he or she
eats that meal drinks that drink
during their recovery just forgets to
thank you it happens we're all human
or let's say they just slipped their
mind or they get busy or something
happens right you're gonna now be
tripping out like oh do they not
appreciate me how dare they they're so
ungrateful you know you're gonna start
second guessing your action now because
of your intention
and my point is eventually with people
and human beings you can't control them
you can't do something and expect
something back from people you can't do
something and expect praise and
compliments and reward you can't expect
reciprocity you can't at the end of the
day you can't control what other people
do the only one you can control is you
compare this to now if I did this for
the sake of Allah I'm gonna give someone
a meal for the sake of Allah
whether they praise me or not they show
me appreciation or not they cherish it
or not they reciprocate it or not I
already know that if I did it for the
sake of Allah Allah has rewarded me
Allah has raised me in rank in what
matters not in this Dunya so it really
doesn't matter what they say or what
they don't say
absolutely 100 100 percent
I'm trying to read the comments from
here and like I'm like half blind right
now so it's kind of difficult too I
don't know if they're following along or
not
yeah I blocked someone today bro oh no
only one that's right I blocked one bro
it was it was a guy
um a man said I'm using lip fillers so
listen listen to me listen to me bro so
I take that as a compliment right I
don't have an issue with that call us
you wanna you wanna you wanna look at
another man's lips bro that's a little
sauce
whatever and then the same troll
proceeds to
um
uh say bro it looks like fives using a
fish eye filter to make his eyes look
bigger or something like that
bro who has time for this type of stuff
say hello my bad I can keep it moving
bro
because that level of clownish behavior
that's not even a compliment you're just
being sauce at that point but Mila bless
you regardless if you're Muslim well I
mean
I'm sorry I'm sorry I found that funny
but um yeah some people just want
problems man like I always said [__]
online yeah it's okay some people are
and that was an example of bad action
bad intention
let's move on so
let's get let's bring it back to
inshallah the other topics so we
discussed the basics
doing things with the right intention
doing the right action as well with the
right intention and what happens if you
don't if you do things that are Haram or
you do things that are good but with the
wrong intention that's something that's
also punishable Allah
would punish us for that potentially
now I want to talk about another very
very basic thing that unfortunately I
think a lot of Muslims lack and that's
professionalism
professionalism is something that you
know is basic you know if you work in
any field you have to have a level of
professionalism but it's not just in the
workspace you actually have to have a
level of professionalism and a level of
Excellency and every Avenue of life you
know some people they go to work and
they they act professional they're
dressed nicely they're looking nice
they're speaking very kindly you know
they're they're using nice professional
sounding words as soon as they get home
Everything Changes they're a whole other
person
and I think the more you can minimize
that
the better you'll be because you will be
authentic and you will be professional
at the same time and I want to quote the
Hadith
and I think is so tremendously powerful
because it speaks about doing things
with Excellence or doing things with a
level of perfection and it talks about
essentially professionalism so the
prophet sallallahu and this is in the 40
Hadith
he said verily Allah has prescribed
excellence in everything
boom we're already off with with
something so tremendous such a banger
already Allah has prescribed excellence
in everything
which means everything you do you have
to do it excellently
can you imagine that I'm not saying if
you don't do excellently you're sinful
but this is what the prophet is telling
us to do Allah has told us to be
excellent in everything and then he says
if you off somebody if you have to or
something then off them in the best
manner something that we don't think
about oh let me do this correctly let me
do this excellently you're offering
someone you don't think about doing it
that way but he says if you have to do
it in the best manner if you have to you
know like head out of slaughtering for
an animal then do it in the best manner
he says let one of you sharpen his knife
so the animal is spared from suffering I
think that last line is so beautiful and
it's so powerful and a lot of people let
it go under the radar inshallah we're
not going to let it slide under the
radar today the process on them he said
let one of you sharpen his knife so the
animal is spared of suffering what does
this mean what does this tell us it
tells us that sometimes when you don't
do things in the most perfect way
sometimes when you don't do things
excellently people will suffer
imagine what I'm trying to tell you guys
today and what five is trying to tell
you guys today if we don't do it in the
best manner sometimes people actually
become hurt
you know if if you want to advise
someone close to you or any person for
that matter and you don't go about it in
the right way sometimes you cause more
damage sometimes cause more harm than
good if you want to go to someone and
say hey I think you're suffering with
this problem sometimes the way you say
it makes them fall into that problem
even more sometimes when you go to
someone you're and you say you're just a
liar you're just a thief you're just a
backbiter you're just a sometimes you're
telling them the things that you know
you think they are and then they start
to believe it and they fall further into
that
so when you don't do things in the best
of manner sometimes people suffer so
again I want to go back to the top of
the Hadith the process on me said Allah
has prescribed excellence in everything
so now think about it every individual
think about it how many things do you
think about doing excellently
is your life a matter of let me do
everything excellently or is it a matter
of let me do whatever let me do the bare
minimum
you know even small things like I'm
gonna I'm gonna check out to work five
minutes early
um but I'm gonna get paid for the full
the full hour you know small things like
that you might see it as small but you
know reflect on this Hadith was that an
excellent thing to do as a person was
that excellent to do as a Muslim not
necessarily so if I want you to jump in
What are some signs of professionalism
or what are some some traits that a
professional would have in any field
that you think people lack today
well number one punctuality this is key
bro across the board no matter what yeah
oh God that's only what go far
self-improvement that's not with Islam
well Allah says in the Quran that
prayers are prescribed at fixed times
for us to remember Allah and for us to
worship Allah in the best manner
possible
we don't have this listen
we don't want to play the hold on police
game but listen I'm gonna say it as it
is delaying prayers until
it's basically time for your next prayer
and you're waiting five minutes I was
victim to this by the way too in the
past
but this is this is not being punctual
this is not having excellence in
professionalism like a brother on me
saying and this it displeases Allah at
the end of the day yes sometimes it's a
Sunday prayer for example the process
and you know this context for that in
general we have to have punctuality for
prayer and in general professionally
we have to have functionality for
everything I don't care if you think
someone's gonna show up late or they
don't take it seriously you got to take
it seriously there's a quote that I we
talked about um you know that how you do
one thing is how you do everything
so let's say you're punctual with work
but you're like you know what work I
have to be punctual you know I have
clients or I have patience or whatever
and they're coming at a specific fixed
time slot appointment right in my
schedule but because of that I don't
have to be punctual after hours no you
do because how you are non-punctual
after hours let's say with meeting
people or friends or other things
it's going to project and rub off on
other areas of your life
and if you don't take those things
seriously you're not going to take other
things seriously
another example is let's say it's time
to go outside and I'm just gonna wear
whatever now obviously as Muslims we
should be
wearing correct hijab so I'm not saying
not to
but if you go outside looking like a bum
you haven't gotten a haircut in a long
time you haven't showered you're not
clean you got ripped clothes old clothes
whatever I'm not this is not a talk
about hello Haram by the way I'm just
saying you're not carrying yourself with
respect like you take yourself seriously
but you expect other people to take
yourself seriously
and let's say because of that it
projects into how you dress period so
even when you're home now you're like
you know what when I go outside I don't
even care how I dress so in the house
there's no one so I'm just gonna dress
however I want to like a bum
and when you pray right you dress
however you want you're not wearing the
best of clothes you're not looking the
most presentable
Allah likes it when you actually look
more presentable and try to look good
for his sake when you're praying a lot
of people didn't know that
it's easy to just roll out of bed and
wear pajamas and pray and I'm not saying
not to do that I do that sometimes too
but Allah loves it when you actually try
to look better and feel better and be
more presentable and professional for
him
and you take your time with Salah that
is better for you so it goes without
saying that punctuality is extremely key
bro before I give the next ones what do
you think about that
yeah absolutely absolutely punctuality
and we know that very well we come to
every stream like five minutes late so
inshallah we're working on that as well
but that we're human we're human too
yeah and that's something that's I think
really underrated and I think a lot of
the things I have on my list and
probably a lot of things you're going to
mention as well fired are very
underrated things people are like oh
yeah that's basic but are you
implementing it yes punctuality is basic
but are you actually implementing it are
you like even something small like your
mom says be home at six for dinner and
you come 6 30 you know you might see
that a small but your mom wants you to
be there at a certain time and you
agreed you know Edris he promised he'd
meet a person at a specific time and the
guy didn't show up
waited hours he sat there waiting hours
us we you know I'm not saying you have
to but us we wait five ten minutes be
like screw this person we wouldn't even
make an excuse we say man they stood me
up blah blah and you'd run out the door
and never talk to them again he waited
hours for the guy and the guy finally
came and said hey I'm sorry I completely
forgot you know but us we're a whole
different story in terms of punctuality
and all that
that's a beautiful Point bro because
when it comes to a societal level with
the community people it will rub off on
people bro if they know you as the guy
that's consistently late they're not
going to take you seriously but more
importantly forget the people right
you yourself will not take yourself
seriously over time
because anytime you tell yourself you're
going to do something as a man and you
don't follow through
you're subconsciously telling yourself
that I'm not capable of doing what I set
out to do
this is deep it's not just you don't
have these logical thoughts consciously
that's not what happens but
subconsciously it limits yourself
and your capability in your eyes
and because you don't do what you said
you're going to do when you're going to
do it next time you're less likely to do
it and then you're even more or less
likely to do it and it's just a downward
negative feedback loop regression into
you basically not being somebody that
accomplishes their goals
it's too far of an analogy into what I'm
saying but the path that you're on if
you do that only leads that way
whereas the opposite is true as well
alhamdulillah
if you tell yourself you're going to do
something when you're gonna do it and
you actually follow through not only
will people know that but you will know
that you prove yourself subconsciously
that you know you're capable that you
can do what you set out to do uh so
punctuality guys once again key
and the next thing that I wanted to
bring up it's something that we've
definitely been working on a lot in the
last few years alhamdulillah
um is going to be your speech right and
it doesn't matter what professional
Avenue you're looking at whether it's
with co-workers whether it's with
friends whether it's with family whether
it's in the Masjid
or even just how you talk to yourself if
you know a lot of sisters talk to
themselves subhanallah
but if we have foul speech
the effects on it are so drastic
compared to what we think it is
and I think there's a Hadith where the
process so mentions that something very
small in our eyes could be huge in the
eyes of Allah
and something big like a sin that we
think Allah will never forgive us it
could be it's very small in the eyes of
Allah Allah could forgive it just like
that so Rami why don't you go into that
a little bit the importance of speech
specifically good speech and refraining
from cussing swearing backbiting which
is a major sin in Islam
yeah so speech I mean is an
all-encompassing term because it doesn't
just Encompass the words that you use or
how many or how few words you use it's
also how you say it the inflection that
you use the tone that you use if you
don't say what you want to say with the
person in mind and with the message in
mind then it might not come out the way
you want and then it actually might be
like I mentioned more harmful than it is
beneficial
so when it comes to speech you know
Allah he tells Musa in the Quran to go
to the worst person we know how horrible
this person is and Allah says go to him
and basically speak to him kindly and
tell them you know let the children of
Israel come with me
this is a horrible person and Allah
commanded Muslim to speak to them kindly
which shows us what actually this is a
side note but it shows us what it shows
us that when you speak nicely or poorly
or or rudely with somebody it's not
about who you're speaking to it's about
who's speaking if you have a bad way of
communicating or if you're a
disrespectful person it doesn't matter
if you're you're saying it
disrespectfully to a bad person or a
good person it's a reflection of who you
are Allah commanded an amazing person to
uphold his amazing nature and just be a
good person and speak kindly because
when you speak kindly it's a reflection
of you being a good person and when you
speak poorly it's a reflection of you
being a bad person and the process was
always good and kind and compassionate
and real and firm with his speech
obviously everything when he needed to
be solo synonym so
speech and I'm not going to be perfectly
at this because maybe in me
communicating to you I'm making my own
mistakes in blunders but the process
you know he wouldn't say too many words
he would say a few words but it would
mean a lot so he wouldn't waffle on
basically Allah and sometimes he would
repeat things three times to really
hammer it in so that people can
understand so speech is one of those
things where you actually really need to
master it and to master it just takes
practice and understanding and that dips
into emotional intelligence and
psychology and understanding people and
what gets them working and moving
inshallah will probably have
an entire episode maybe two on emotions
and emotional intelligence and all that
but
if I did that answer your question
because I wanted to go through a few
things um
perfect so just for the sake of time to
not carry on too long
um some other signs of professionalism
would be things like other than
punctuality would be things like having
standards every Muslim should have a
standard and if they don't know what
their standard is who cares know what
Allah standard is and then make that
your standard because that's the only
standard that matters that's the only
criteria that we should care about as
Muslims next is consistency right I
mentioned the Hadith earlier the most
loved Deeds to Allah are the ones that
are consistent even if they're small
right they're consistent even if they're
small so every time you walk in the
Masjid give a dollar or two instead of
giving 20 bucks uh you know once a year
when you walk in you're feeling generous
also
about speech and everything like I was
mentioning being respectful towards
ourselves first and foremost not making
a fool out of ourselves not bantering
too much making you know Silly jokes or
disrespectful or or crude jokes being
respectful to our peers speaking to them
kindly and nicely
um upholding their honor as well as our
own and you know to others out there
even the strangers we have you know they
have rights over us as well they're
human beings they're a living creature
you know we have to uphold our rights
and respect towards them as well
and bro just to add to that point of
people that make dirty jokes or
excessive jokes and laughter and all the
process of mentioned beware of excessive
laughter
it's not good for us in our relationship
with Allah yeah what what something
affects us on a physical
three-dimensional Material World level
might not be the same as what happens on
a spiritual level so some people think
oh I listen to music I'm fine okay yeah
you're fine in this three-dimensional
world you're not physically
deteriorating right or at least all we
know of
but what's happening to your spirit to
your soul we don't know we can't see it
you know so don't think just because
something's not happening to you
physically it's not affecting you
spiritually and excess of laughter foul
speech that's definitely one of those
things because superficially it seems
like oh what's the difference between me
saying this word or not saying that word
yeah 100 even things like banter you
know just talking uselessly for too long
is something that we shouldn't do as
Muslims because the doors that it opens
are you know could be dangerous could
open the door to back biting you could
open the door to slandering it could
open the door to saying something that
yeah you just can't take back so even
things like that we have to be careful
of next is being organized organized
with your time organized with your
things organized with other people's
belongings and other people's time you
know it's very important being focused
you have to be driven and focused as a
Muslim you need to know uh what is
important and be steadfast on it you
know things like having in your prayer
focus in your prayer things like having
taqwa and tawakul you know God
Consciousness uh you know that's that's
very very important in your life and
lastly being well managed
I don't mean that someone else is
managing you I mean that you manage
yourself well you know your weaknesses
you know your strengths you know your
your Pros your cons your shortcomings
and then you work on them and you manage
yourself you know that if I were to do
this I'd be stepping out of my range a
little too much let me hold back
no that's something alhamdulillah I
think that I've learned very recently as
well just know your balance and and do
things uh slowly inshallah if you need
to and quickly as well if you need to
and if you can just manage yourself
while insha Allah
um were there any final quick
um you know traits of a professional
that you wanted to add fire
I didn't want to add sober patience
and understanding that sometimes you're
doing the right thing but you just
haven't given enough time yet
and just having that trust in Allah
um another thing is
uh perseverance
kind of goes hand in hand with
consistency but always expecting a
higher standard from yourself and
operating at that standard no matter
what
um and then the last thing I'll do or
I'll say what professionalism is how you
are when no one's watching
so maybe being authentic or sincere but
many people are on point when other
people are watching many people pray in
front of other people many people do
good deeds in front of other people but
behind closed doors they're not really
operating at any standard let alone a
good best standard so understand that
Allah is always watching the Angels
always watching so it goes without
saying that we should always be on point
no matter whose eyes are on us
absolutely absolutely beautifully said
and now
moving on to something else that I think
unfortunately people lack tremendously
nowadays Muslims and non-muslims but
it's more shameful when Muslims lack
these things because we have the Quran
we have the Sera of the Prophet saws
telling us
how to live life and how to act and how
to behave so something that's missing
are manners just good mannerisms with
things like marriage you'd say look for
a good character manners and good
religion
so even with things like getting married
and being with your family manners are
something that are of the utmost
importance when you go out in public
and people see you have Bad Manners
you're basically telling them stay away
from me
and when you have good manners you're
telling them I'm a person you can trust
I'm a person who will be there for you
I'm a person who you know genuinely
cares just by virtue of having good
manners you hold yourself up to a
certain level and that's very important
the process and there are many many a
Hadith talking about the importance of
having good character so this one is is
uh in a tobarani and then the rest will
be in bukhari so this one said the most
beloved of Allah slaves
um are those with the Best Manners now
the rest of are all sahir and sahil
bukhari messenger of Allah
he said nothing is heavier on the scale
of these than one's good manners can you
imagine that
can you imagine that you think you're
you know you're extra Salah the extra
prayers that you pray you think the
little bit of Charity that you gave you
think you know you smiled at somebody
you think oh yeah I'm going to heaven
now
but maybe you have bad manners and that
is the heaviest thing on the scale
that's what the prophet was saying
nothing is heavier than good manners
process on me also said a person may
attain through good manners the same
level of virtue as those who spend their
nights in prayer could you imagine
staying up all night in prayer or most
of the night in prayer every single
night the level of virtue and
righteousness you'd reach you can reach
that just by having good manners and
it's something that's so beneficial as
well
the process enemy also said the best
among you in Islam are those with the
Best Manners
The Best of You are those with the Best
Manners what more do you need to know
okay let me get my mannerism straight
inshallah and lastly the Hadith I have
here
when he was asked about the definition
of righteousness people ask them what is
righteousness
the process son of he said righteousness
is a good character
righteousness is good character how
beautiful is that
you know go ask a Christian or a Jew or
anyone else what is righteousness
and look at what they're going to answer
you
and look at what the process defines it
as he says righteousness is having good
character how beautiful is that
the process or Allah he tells us in the
Quran you know what good character is
and traits that we should have and
things we should avoid he tells us not
to lie all right speak the truth even if
it's against your own self he says don't
insult he says don't be wasteful don't
backbite you know keep your Oaths and
your promises and so on and so forth
so to know what good manners are just
study the Quran study the theater of the
prophet sallam and look at the lives of
some of the NBR some of the prophets
that existed but fired what are some
manners that you think people are
lacking nowadays
um
number one thing is integrity
people don't have value bro people don't
have
a code of ethics that they stand by
so sometimes they have a boundary maybe
with themselves or other people and they
uphold that and then when it comes to
other things or other times when
somebody asks them something or
basically coerces them they're very easy
to Cave or given right and as men one of
the biggest things that I will bring up
is controlling ourselves and our sexual
desires as men
this is something that is a very good
litmus test of a man's integrity and
women believe it or not can see that
they can sense that that are you going
to be the type that would most likely
when I'm not here you're gonna cheat on
me you're going to give into your
desires or do you have a code of ethics
do you have integrity are you okay at
the end of the day
um so I will bring up Integrity but what
are your thoughts on that so far yeah
100 that's that's definitely a great
great one and that's unfortunately one
that a lot of people miss you know even
being you know in small ways you know
when you're dealing with someone maybe
they buy something from you and
um or sorry maybe you buy something from
them and they you they give you change
back but they actually give you too much
if you have integrity as a Muslim you
will say Hey you actually gave me too
much and give the money back things like
that even if it's just a dollar or two
are very important as Muslims but what
else fired
hmm
next thing is I want you to give one two
and then I'll give another one okay well
one that I think is is huge is
backbiting
people bro people back about like
nothing these days they they'll have
full backbiting sessions just a bunch of
people will get together just to talk
bad about somebody else who isn't there
to defend themselves nobody would defend
them they would all sit there for hours
just talking mad stuff about this person
and they'll act like it's nothing they
would walk away
foreign
yeah unfortunately so this is something
that we need to avoid even if it's not
us saying the words walk away tell
someone listen I'm going to be honest I
don't want to hear this stuff
I don't wanna I don't want to be here
when you're back biting and I advise you
not to and walk away
yeah bro and it's tough because not
everyone sees it that way unfortunately
yeah but it doesn't matter what they
think you know only what Allah and his
messenger says
number two is going to be something that
I noticed in a lot of people
is they're too jokey like they're always
joking around and I'm not saying don't
have fun in life don't have a smile on
your face don't laugh and giggle and
have a good time no one's saying to be
super strict and boring or anything like
that but I'm talking to those people
that are always joking around they're
always laughing you can tell in the room
they're literally acting like they're
intoxicated or inebriated for some
reason and there's no sense of conduct
it's not
it's not overly laughing but it's almost
in a goofy cornball dancing monkey type
thing where their their main intention
is always how do I just get people to
laugh how do I just make fun of
everything and it just it shows a lack
of security in yourself as a man it
shows a lack of you are content with who
you are and Allah knows best Allah knows
who I am that's all I care about it's
it's a level of those that and
especially men today that are laughing
too much talking too much always arguing
always debating overly talking
it all stems from ego that I need to
show that I'm right I need to show them
how much I know I need to show them that
I'm funny or I need to basically prove a
point
and not only does this limit you but it
limits your connection to Allah because
at the end of the day you're always
looking for external validation with
people for your ego the main goal is to
let go of your ego so you don't care
about how you come across you do your
part and then as a man you just sit back
you know you've done everything in the
eyes of Allah possible and you leave the
rest to him
absolutely absolutely 100 I have
exhausted my list of things I'm sure
everyone at home can come up with
probably 10 more on their own I'm sure
you have a lot more fried but we only
have about nine minutes inshallah before
we have to wrap up so I think it would
be good just to start talking about
emotional intelligence we're not going
to go into the whole thing because
listen the whole thing would take
probably an entire course people have
written books on this people have you
know this is a whole field of study for
some people so we're just going to talk
about things on a very basic level and
some things to watch out for again some
of the basics to keep in mind when
you're dealing with people so firstly
find what is emotional intelligence if
someone were to ask you
emotional intelligence or EQ is
basically
a trait of having
empathy sympathy
and basically reading the room and
situations and just being more mindful
having that connection with other people
it's it's far too nuanced of a shade of
gray to be giving you a simple one-liner
of a definition but I think giving some
examples can definitely help
so there's a Hadith were
poses um was laying with Aisha his wife
and it was that time of the month for
her she basically gets up to either go
somewhere or go to the washroom or I'm
not sure Mommy can correct me if I'm
wrong but she gets up and the prophecy
song looks at her and says when you come
back to me come back closer
like make sure you come back to me even
closer than you were when you left
which goes to show that you know
sometimes women are self-conscious or
whatever that time of the month they
feel weird they feel gross they feel
groggy and whatever
and the postal read that
and basically without saying that
specifically just completely removed all
those doubts or insecurities by saying
come back to me closer you know it's
this is emotional intelligence it's not
just saying what needs to be said and
just only caring about yourself but
you're making sure you're taking the
best objective stance possible another
thing is let's say you are with a friend
and you're somebody that you like to be
respectful and you like to be respected
as well but let's say they had a bad day
or let's say somebody passed away in
their family
and they were supposed to meet you at
five o'clock
let's say they come at 5 30. now you
know they're having a bad day you know
they lost their loved one and they're
grieving or whatever first of all the
fact that they're even meeting you
subhanallah bless them and Elevate them
in rank but let's say at that point you
realize you know what I'm gonna go off
on them I'm gonna say yo how could you
be 30 minutes late you know we were
supposed to do this we were supposed to
watch this I was gonna say watch this
movie but let's say we had this
appointment and we know we were going to
do this but now we we missed this
appointment we missed our time slot
that's you not being emotionally
intelligent now if this is a pattern
sure you can bring it up but reading the
room and given the context how they went
through what they went through
it would be far more emotionally
intelligent of you to forbear and forego
checking them that one time because you
understand that you know what okay maybe
they're not
in the best state of mind maybe their
life isn't going according to plan let
me have a little bit of emotional
intelligence empathy for them
but you can feel free to add anything to
that yeah 100 100 I think continuing
with like examples and and a
step-by-step process would be really
important for everyone so again everyone
understand that we're going to
inshaallah one day
have a full episode maybe two maybe
three maybe an entire playlist on how
deep this issue is on emotional
intelligence and how to communicate
properly how to make people feel better
about themselves and how to live a
fruitful life Insha'Allah but we're just
going to stick with the basics for today
so
just like anything else this requires
the theoretical aspect the concepts the
understand you know the steps that you
write down on a paper that you can refer
to and then it takes practice as well as
well pardon me so you know you're gonna
deal with you know your your parents
you're going to deal with your siblings
you're going to deal with your spouse
you're going to deal with people at work
you can you're going to deal with
customers practice with the people
around you you know firstly
observe them and really care about them
a lot of the time when we're discussing
with people we're focused on what we're
going to say so we're not even listening
to the person listen to them hear them
out forget about being right or being
wrong or sounding smart or sounding dumb
just forget about all that just think
about their perspective when they're
speaking well how does their face look
how is their tone do they seem happy do
they seem upset what could possibly be
going on in their head right now if you
can understand these things then you're
a step closer to be able uh to have a
positive and fruitful discussion or
experience with them and that's
important because if you can produce
good experiences for people you'll make
them happier you'll make them more
positive and you'll bring them closer to
you the process of me had a beautiful
Talent a beautiful gift of making
everyone around them feel like they're
the closest person to him making
everyone around him feel special
who else could do that
who actually tries to do that even or
cares enough to you know small things
like when someone's speaking you turn
you face them with your whole body
that's what the process used to do so
observe the person speaking and really
ask yourself in the moment you know
what's going on in their head while
listening to them there are words that
they're saying and then there's
something that they mean because not not
everyone most people actually when they
communicate it's not a direct way very
few people just come and tell you point
blank period XYZ they will be around the
bush so really try and extrapolate what
they're saying and what's at the root of
the issue
and then once you understand that ask
yourself what can I do to positively
contribute to their life what can I do
to positively contribute to this
experience for them
and it it's not about you again Focus
it's not about you it's about them and
if you remember that and I think you
guys should maybe watch the stream back
take a few notes here and there and put
all these things in the practice sha
Allah because if you actually Implement
these things you'll see not just your
your life go up or the the uh
um what's the word I'm looking for
the state of your life not only you're
going to see it quality of your life
yeah thank you the quality of your life
the state of your life and the other
people around you it's the same thing
because you're going to be more
beneficial to the people around you as
well
I'll give a quick example before we read
out some of these super chats at the end
but
a lot of people
I deal with a lot of non-muslim clients
sometimes and they they have girlfriends
obviously they're not Muslim
but a lot of them they have this thing
where it's like they spend too much time
with their girl or their woman or their
spouse
and I was talking to brother Rami about
this a few hours ago that
you might think she wants your time you
might think that she wants to spend time
with you so you stop going to the gym
because she wants to spend time with you
you stop making money and doing overtime
because your intention is oh you know
what I want to make her happy and I
don't want to hurt her feelings or
whatever
bro you doing that
is quite literally the worst thing that
you could do for her and if you cared
about her you wouldn't do those things
because now let's say it's time to
protect her some altercation was to go
down
but you actually don't know how to fight
because you haven't been going to the
gym you haven't been training I'm a
mayor or whatever you've you've just
been being weak because you want to just
snuggle next to her and watch Netflix
how is that doing the best thing for her
to protect her or let's say instead of
making money now it's time to basically
help something happen you guys can't pay
rent money's sure and now you guys are
on the street God forbid
but do you really care about it then
because instead of actually making the
money to provide and protect you've just
been doing the more easy thing the more
comfortable thing
so operating at this high standard of
Excellence is quite literally the best
thing that you can do for those around
you along with yourself
and just merely looking at it in a
one-dimensional oh
if I just make this person happy by
doing what I want all the time then
everything will be taken care of no it
might bring you temporary pleasure and
comfort
but at the expense of you borrowing the
from your long-term security and success
absolutely 100 percent
so I think with that being said that
kind of concludes the basic things that
we wanted to speak about today again
just to recap a lot of people lack in
the basic fundamental
aspects of life you know things like
manners character morals intention good
actions and emotional intelligence
caring about other people focusing on
you know how they how they look in
society how they appear if they're being
a good part of society or a bad part of
society these are basic things and since
people lack the basics
it's hard to for them to teach
themselves and they can't def they
definitely can't teach anyone else so
it's with those you know who have the
knowledge it's upon those with the
knowledge to teach it and convey it and
that's okay sometimes you need someone
to show you how to shop
yeah even shop you're at the grocery
store sometimes you need someone to show
you how to shop the small things getting
good deals picking good products knowing
what you want knowing what you need
sometimes you need people to show you
how to do basic things like that picking
up flowers as well what makes a good uh
you know
uh what's the word I'm looking for
okay
yeah yeah what makes it a good bouquet
what makes something look pretty by the
way you're muted fight I was gonna say
come on Romeo you should know this yeah
sorry I just get the flowers I don't
know the terms but oh that's facts
my wife and mom are very lucky
I'm blessed to have them from the net
but back to the main point you know
these Basics are things that you guys
need to practice in real life so that
being said alhamdulillah let's get to
some of the super chats uh that we
weren't able to pull up on the Fly
inshallah bro we gotta rap in five
minutes hard time because uh I gotta go
to the Masjid inshallah we got more grip
soon
I want to share something with your
brothers in private I've sent an email
and message you on Instagram
we will check it out
for the 27 dollars
uh Lucid Wen and sha Allah soon don't
worry have patience that's one of the
things we discussed inshallah we will
have a stream with them soon inshallah
two to three months it'll happen
um bro don't even read this I really
hope you're joking bro
I really hope that you're joking around
it probably is I don't think anyone
would say that in a serious way
um good evening can I can a woman become
Muslim even if her husband doesn't
absolutely your Islam never relies on
another person whether they're your
mother your father your child your
spouse no matter who it is and we
actually have amazing Muslims that were
married to really bad people once upon a
time or maybe even you know they died
Muslims and their spouse was a horrible
person so except Islam and don't let
anybody hold you back even if you have
to do it just in your heart between you
and God you should go for it inshallah
because Islam is the truth
and allow us to be righteous and stay in
this great path to please him and only
him and if you please people as a
byproduct call us that's fine if you
please Adonia as a byproduct
and you get likes and you get validation
from the Dunya as a byproduct that's
fine
but never go for that
if it happens it happens and definitely
understand these things
external validation Fame this stuff
isn't necessarily evil
unnecessary evil is something that it's
only it's evil but if it's necessary for
example like us we have this podcast
right
we're all here making videos we have
Subs we have a following people
recognize us it's not something per se
that is an easy test for a lot of people
and many people let it get to their
heads or they have narcissism or
whatever
and for us we're not like that anyway
we're we love looking at you know
anytime somebody comes and they they say
oh yo I'm your fan or whatever like bro
you're a brother in Islam may Allah
bless you but the main thing that I'm
getting to is having these things are a
necessary evil for us we're doing dawa
you know but if you're out here trying
to get Fame clout and all this external
validation please Adonia please the
people and your intention isn't for
Allah then you really got to ask
yourself why are you doing this because
ultimately at the end of the day if
you're not doing something for the sake
of Allah what are you really doing it
for
because this life is short you're gonna
die one day just like that and that one
day might be tomorrow it might be today
it might be in the next hour
not to get metal but how are you going
to guarantee it's not tell me that you
can't guarantee it's not and when it's
all said and done
eternity is going to be way more
valuable and important and a major
priority than temporary
what 50 60 70 80 years of life if we're
lucky
so this life is a test if you're not
doing anything for the sake of Allah
really ask yourself why are you doing it
why are you Muslim you wake up every
single day and people know you're Muslim
but why are you really Muslim
just so you can like sleep it off day by
day waste your life away
you know barely get your five daily
prayers and that's it like or are we
really trying to lead by example are we
really trying to save these people from
John them these people that need
guidance in dawah and they need someone
to be an example for them I also
mentioned that dawah is an obligation
convey for me even if it's one Ayah in
the Quran so what are we really doing
this for
absolutely absolutely just to make sure
you said the process that I'm said to
convey from me even if it's just one I
am correct okay perfect so I thought I
misheard that so with that being said I
think that's a beautiful note to end on
may Allah bless you all for watching
please like and share the video with
those who you think need it
um and by the way basically everyone
needs to hear these basic things even if
they know them the prophet son told us
that there is goodness and a reminder
May Allah forgive us for our sins and
our shortcomings anything that's good
that we set us from Allah the most
gracious the most merciful the most high
the absolute and the Supreme subhanahu
ta'ala and anything that was wrong or
that was incorrect or misconstrued is
only from ourselves and from shaytan
well Allah has said is the accursed may
Allah again forgive us for our sins and
shortcomings and Elevate Us in this life
in the next may Allah except from us are
good and pardon us on the day of
judgment may Allah protect us from the
punishment of this life and the grave in
the afterlife as well may Allah grant us
great spouses and children will be The
Offspring of you know us as
and who will be the coolness of our eyes
may Allah allow us to be leaders for the
righteous I mean and with that being
said Allah